it's kicking off awards season you being
recognized for your incredible work how
are you feeling starting this award
season off here at Palm Springs well
first of all I feel grateful that I had
the opportunity this year to make a
movie like pain and glory is the eighth
movie that I do with Pedro almodóvar we
met 40 years ago so I feel like we close
a circle I started you know many years
ago I am right now I feel totally spaced
out you have been 18 hours in a plane I
am coming from the stage I was
performing in Malaga in my hometown
where I have a theatre I saw from the
plane and I am here you know but but I'm
very happy okay so you're exhausted
you're jet-lagged but you're happy by
the way as much incredible work as
you're doing everybody is yelling we
love you zorro zorro zorro zorro do
people yell that at you on the street no
no they do more weird things and you
know for example mothers they're saying
to the kids in supermarkets look that
guy is Puss in Boots the kids are
looking at me like oh my god my mother
just became completely nuts so yeah no
but some of the characters that I have
done they obviously has some impact on
audiences iconic roles yeah yeah
is there any that you would revisit now
is the time of sequels and reboots any
character you'd love to play again no I
you know I just know I don't have no
strategy for them and you know I think
that they all you know I did them when
the time came to do it no I'm looking
for new things I want new characters and
new new things that's what I am looking
for you know these people are screaming
for another Zorro like I know you know I
heard them I'd you know and we have so
many people around so they may just hear
that give me you know if I do I know
this or I would be the character that
Anthony Hopkins play in the first one
yeah I mean I'm gonna be 60 next year so
I don't know when you place or run you
have to be on horseback or very long and
certified and stuff like that be harsh
next generation right away Anthony
getting a lot of recognition for the two
popes this year do you guys see and
touch it off and have you ever no
unfortunately no I've you know I mean we
did a movie with Woody Allen together
like three or four years ago but ever
since and I never saw and you know I
admire very much
he's worked and I saw actually the two
pops and I thought that it was a
beautiful movie how proud is your family
I know you're such a family man how
proud are they of you for this
recognition that you're getting my
season well they they they are because
they said that to me my my daughter's my
song my ex also is very proud na na and
I call them my family that my American
family I go tomorrow to Los Angeles I'm
gonna see them but yes they are proud
they're pushing their and the Cora did a
beautiful speech actually in some other
work and she gave me and so I would I
was beautiful just to see your kids you
know you know they're giving you the tap
in the back is that is a very nice thing
[Music]